what's he doing your father's gone as
the father of the realm it is my duty to
give you away to your husband hey
everybody it's Charlie and can we just
talk about Sansa for a minute I don't
think she's doing so hot I mean wait
it's my Game of Thrones Season 4 preview
for Sansa Stark let's talk about where
Sansa left off in season 3 as well as
some of the new castings in season 4 and
some of the events and the books that
haven't happened yet and try and figure
out what sands is going to be doing this
next season so at the end of season 3
Sansa finally got her fairytale wedding
to Tyrion oh wait that wasn't a
fairytale wedding that was the worst
wedding in the history of weddings
followed by the worst wedding night in
the history of wedding nights during my
Tyrion preview for season 4 I kind of
compared him to Sansa and now that they
kind of occupied the same social place
and Kings Landing right now they're both
trying to get murdered and trying to
avoid getting stepped on it's kind of
fitting that the two ended up together
but obviously I don't expect that to
last because things are always changing
in King's Landing
remember Tyrion was under strict orders
to deflower her and he did not and
various in Littlefinger both have plans
for her as well as king crossbow but
based on a new character that was cast
for a storyline that takes place in the
Eyrie I really think that she's going to
end up there by the end of the season we
haven't been there since season 1 and
remember it's not a very safe place but
Littlefinger agreed to marry Lysa Arryn
so obviously he has to go there at some
point and he's going to try and take
Sansa with him I feel like in the book
Sansa is kind of a bystander to most of
the bigger action but her story really
does pick up in season 4 I think a lot
of the action that she's going to see
will happen after she leaves King's
Landing eventually I don't know which
episode that's going to come in but I do
expect that to happen this season but
let me know if you agree but don't you
feel like all the characters on Game of
Thrones go through a lot of the same
beats at least the main characters they
start out of this really safe place
where they kind of understand the
environment around them someone betrays
them and then they find out that a lot
of the things they believed in or
illusions and then they go on the run
obviously that's going to happen to
Sansa again but I feel like with the
winds of winter coming somatically all
the characters are going to be on the
run by the time that the army of White
Walkers descends on King's Landing so if
you think the Sansa has it bad right now
don't worry everyone else is gonna get
it in the end beware those frost blades
but let me know what you think is going
to happen to Sansa this season is she
going to make it to the Eyrie will she
get out of King's Landing well
Littlefinger do with her in the books
he's able to kind of lure her away with
the promise that he's going to help her
retake Winterfell
obviously that plan gets kind of
convoluted and in the books right now
she's kind of left in this cliffhanger
so it'll be really interesting to see
how her character continues to develop
but I really do feel like she's getting
more and more interesting and I do feel
like the actress sophie Turner has
really kind of come into her own while
the show's been going on obviously her
character hasn't been given a lot in the
first couple seasons people like Peter
Dinklage and Lena Headey get most of the
scenes but I really do feel like she's
able to do a lot with very very little
so obviously Sansa is still going to try
and avoid being stepped on by a lot of
different people in season four but
anything is a step up from king crossbow
here let me know what some of your
favorite things about the character are
though what are some of your favorite
moments for her in the first couple
seasons and what kind of moments do you
think she's gonna get in season four
obviously the more popular actors like
Kit Harington and Lena Headey Peter
Dinklage will probably get more scenes
so we might not see all the things that
happen to Sansa in the books so by
popular demand my next game of Thrones
Season 4 preview will be for Jon Snow be
sure to subscribe to get that video that
we'll post on Monday
remember I'm also in the middle of an
attack on Titan marathon so I'll be
posting another video for that on Sunday
and legend decor is back tonight so be
sure to watch Nickelodeon it's gonna be
amazing I'll post a video for that late
tonight if you really want to help me
out please like and share this video and
you can click here to watch all my other
Game of Thrones Season 4 previews and
you can click here to get my review for
the first couple of episodes on a tech
on titan it's actually really cool
seriously you should check it out thanks
so much for watching high five see you
guys Malaysian decor review
you